in case you hadn't already noticed
everything is getting super duper gay
corporations have gone gay sports teams
have gone gay and now a beloved cartoon
character from the late 1960s has after
53 years in the closet gone gay two
and as promised here are your Scooby
Snacks
thank you
that's Velma there just absolutely
drooling at the Velma dressed up like a
1970s lady drooling at the site of this
kind of 2022 looking lesbian lady little
Velma is officially a lesbian
before the year is through I have no
doubt that Mickey will go trans and
Popeye will get into s m but for now
Velma is a lesbian because Hollywood has
in its own words a not so secret gay
agenda but why
why why does Velma after all these years
need to be a lesbian
some people are actually arguing that
Velma has always been a lesbian why
because she's frumpy and has short hair
that's not very nice to lesbians
because Velma doesn't have a boyfriend
Shaggy doesn't have a girlfriend does
that mean that Shaggy's gay
the person Shaggy spends the most time
with his Scooby-Doo does that mean that
shaggy is into that weird bestiality
thing that the Biden nuclear energy guy
photographs himself doing I don't think
so I certainly hope not
why does every single thing
have to be gay including half century
old cartoons
because narrative matters of course
narrative matters more than just about
anything else in politics that's why the
left spends so much time and energy
rewriting the past
whoever controls the past whoever
controls the past controls the present
whoever controls the present controls
the future I'm Michael Knowles it's the
Michael Knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday is from the drummer's
workshop at Norm's music I feel like
this guy has had a lot of my favorite
comments before he says of course Biden
is Puerto Rican who do you think taught
Jill Biden how to speak Spanish SI SE
puade a great point a very good point
and I'm I'm sure that uh when Joe was
recounting his childhood experiences
with the guys from the neighborhood he
was just translating into English for us
because obviously that bad dude that
that uh muy malombre that he was dealing
with was of course Elkhorn Papo he just
went up to Elkhorn Papo El Chapo corn
Papo and he he had a real a real tough
time they had a real they had a real it
was sort of like West Side Story kind of
and and that's that's the way that Joe
Biden grew up of course he had to
protect himself you have to protect
yourself in your home that's why you got
to check out a ring right now head on
over to ring.com Knowles this season is
very very busy I'm on the road
constantly giving speeches all around
the country but I can feel protected why
I am so grateful for ring alarm now you
might say ring isn't that the video
doorbell company where you can see and
speak to whoever's at your door no
matter where you are in your house in
the office in the world yeah they also
have an alarm
not only do they have an alarm to
protect your whole home
they've gone pro ring alarm Pro is a
whole home security system with
available professional monitoring when
you subscribe to ring protect Pro ring
alarm Pro combines a security system
with a fast Euro Wi-Fi 6 router for home
security and network security in one
device plus with a ring protect Pro
subscription which is an amazing deal by
the way you can get professional
monitoring for the ultimate piece of
mind if anything happens professional
monitoring calls you and can request
emergency services this busy season
you got to be like me you got to be a
pro head on over to ring.com Knowles
that is ring.com Knowles
speaking of sexual eccentricity big news
in the 2022 scene
Beto O'Rourke has a huge endorsement he
was just endorsed by Harry Styles
the pop singer which means that Beto
O'Rourke has an absolute lock on the men
who wear dresses vote birds of a feather
flock together so it is no surprise that
Beto who has been known to Don some
ladies garments now and again would have
a lock on Harry Styles who I think has
entirely stopped wearing pants
only wear his dresses no surprise also
that Harry Styles would endorse Beto
Harry Styles is a huge lib he is a big
gun control proponent he's done work
with every town which is one of the
left-wing gun control groups he's worn a
pride flag as clothing and now he's
supporting Beto okay does this really
move the needle very much
I don't know I don't live in Texas I
have a lot of friends from Texas
and I don't think an endorsement from
Harry Styles is exactly going to swing
that race you're seeing a lot of
desperation out of that race in
particular because Beto now is just a
multi-election loser
he was a pretty much unremarkable member
of the House of Representatives then he
runs for president and loses and and he
was so celebrated when he launched his
campaign glossy covers a Vanity Fair and
then he went absolutely nowhere then he
decided he was going to run against Ted
Cruz for the senate in Texas that again
didn't go anywhere now he's running for
governor it just looks sad it looks
really really sad the people just don't
want him so you speaking of narrative
the the Democrats are losing control of
the narrative
and I think Beto and a lot of the other
Dems are headed for defeat in November
because the Democrat policies are
failing The Narrative is not matching
reality people are catching on to that
and the Democrats have no answers there
was such an embarrassing moment
yesterday at the White House poor Karine
Jean-Pierre hardest job in the world and
she's not up to it even if it weren't
the hardest job in the world Karine
Jean-Pierre was asked about the gas
prices because you see the Biden
Administration took a lot of credit when
the gas prices went down but what
happens when gas prices go up again
you've said the president was
responsible for gas prices coming down
is the president responsible for gas
prices going up
so it's a lot more nuanced than that
right um Peter you know this you know
this Peter there's a lot when when good
stuff happens it's very simple we're
responsible when bad stuff happens
though Peter it's very nuanced and
complicated
this is pretty sad this is what happens
when you hear this especially in
Academia
whenever these Eggheads in Academia
don't have an answer for something they
say well it's very problematic it's
problematic and nuanced you see there's
no there's so many sides to this issue
no well what is it either the President
is responsible for gas prices or he's
not
you you could even say that gas prices
are complicated and the president has
some influence over them but doesn't
have total influence over them you could
say that world events dictate gas prices
much more than the president but the
president still can do certain things
fine whatever but what you can't say is
that the President is responsible when
the prices go down but not responsible
when the prices go up
you just can't say that they're right
either the president affects gas prices
or not the degree to which he affects
them
is the same when the prices go up and
when the prices go down but they have no
answer for that and and so they just
keep spinning their wheels I don't think
that persuades anybody you are seeing
Democrat policies
failing in funnier and funnier ways
my favorite example of this lately Great
Piece in Daily wire on it by my friend
Amanda prestigiacomo
there's this kid in New York he refers
to himself as a punk kid we don't know
his his true identity because he
doesn't want to come out and arouse the
ire of New York public officials because
he totally milked a ridiculous lib
program to the tune of twenty one
thousand dollars so here's what happened
the Attorney General of New York Leticia
James
institutes this big gun buyback program
and gun buyback programs are when the
state come in and they give you money if
you turn in your guns and they'll
frequently give you more than the fair
market value of your guns and this is
always just a publicity stunt there is
absolutely no evidence that this reduces
gun crime or murders or shootings or
anything like that whatsoever
there are actually studies that show
that it doesn't do that affirmatively
show that there is no effect here okay
uh on on gun crime but they do it
because it makes headlines and it looks
like they're being really proactive and
so Leticia James that's what she does
she creates the gun buyback program in
New York
and this guy he just identifies himself
as chem I think Kem
he gets a 200 3D printer
and he prints out the lower receivers
and frames of guns this these really
cheap plastic is Just Junk basically and
he prints it out on his 200 cheap
printer then he goes in and he trades
every single one of these
gun parts for a 500 gift card and so he
shows up to the gun buyback program they
say how many guns do you have that you
want to turn over for Public Safety goes
I don't know how many are going to let
me turn over I got I got like 40 in my
truck and so after a little bit of
negotiation he turns over
these guns
40 42 of them
and he says it ended with the guy and a
lady from the budget office finally
coming around with the 42 gift cards and
Counting them in front of me
42 and why because Leticia James is
getting guns off the streets and out of
our communities is one of the many ways
my office is working to protect New York
families and combat Rising crime rates
so the thing about the gun buyback is
the gang bangers are not going to go and
give you their guns they're not going to
do it for 500 that's for sure these guys
are making way more money with their
guns the actual criminals who are going
out who need their guns to do their jobs
they're not going to participate so
sometimes law-abiding gun owners hand
over their guns which means that the
potential victims are the only people
who end up getting disarmed here but it
also creates a bunch of perverse
incentives if you can go out and and go
buy some guns or produce some gun parts
and then turn them over and make more
money than you just paid for them that
creates an Arbitrage opportunity and you
get to totally scam the program
which of course this kid did and I give
him a lot of a lot of credit for it
there are consequences to ignorant
incompetent public officials we talked
about this yesterday politics is not
just about ideology and politics is not
just about you know which philosophers
you like to read and Amaya Marxist or a
fascist or a neo-liberal or a this
sister that is a lot of politics is just
basic competence do you understand basic
incentives do you know how to make the
government working how to fill the
potholes and these people are not
competent it actually this gives me a
lot of Hope the fact that this woman is
so incompetent because this is the lady
who's supposed to bring down Donald
Trump remember this is the New York
attorney general is going to demolish
the Trump organization and finally get
Trump once and for all his backs against
the wall the walls are closing in right
this is the person who's going to take
down Trump I think Donald is going to be
just fine I've never been more hopeful
that the man's going to make it back to
the White House than to think that this
lady is his big opponent right now on
the legal front
the left is not omnipotent
I think sometimes we conservatives
when we realize the scope of the problem
we lose hope we despair we get very
black pilled okay to use the lingo of
the cool hip Zoomers
we
we say wait a second
the political fight it's not really just
the Republicans versus the Democrats in
a neutral Public Square oh my gosh it's
the Republicans well it's really the
conservatives versus
the Democrats the press the corporations
the Academia the big Tech oligarchs the
bureaucracy the this the that this that
and even against many Republicans who
are just squishes oh my gosh the whole
deck is stacked against us there's no
way we can ever win
yes it's not a fair fight it's not
evenly matched there's no neutral Public
Square the libs are dominant that's true
but the left is not omnipotent
this is where so many people go down a
bad path when they start talking about
the vast conspiracies that control the
world yeah there are conspiracies of
course there are yeah there are shady
cabals of oligarchs who meet in
smoke-filled rooms and decide how
they're going to Institute a great reset
and and rework the world in their own
image yeah that that all happens
but where the theories sort of fall
apart a little bit is those people are
not omnipotent they're human beings just
like me and you they're Fallen creatures
their power is not perfect
look at the incompetence of people like
Joe Biden look at the incompetence of
people like Kareem Jean-Pierre look at
the fact that these people who control
not only the the culture and the
education system they control the social
media they control the Public Square
they can censor pretty much whatever
they want
and even still at least half the people
and I think frankly most people on most
issues totally have their number
they're not omnipotent okay
Joe Biden just got in a little bit of
trouble for discussing this he tweeted
Out quote my dad used to say Joey don't
compare me to the almighty compare me to
the alternative and here's the deal
Democrats want a codify roe Republicans
won a national ban on abortion the
choice is clear
did you catch did you catch that he
deleted this tweet by the way do you
know why he deleted it because oopsie
Daisy he actually
compared himself and his family at least
to uh the devil and I assume that some
of Biden's pollsters came into the
office after he dashed that one off or
after his Handler dashed that one off
but Biden doesn't handle this himself
obviously and and said hey Mr President
hey guys
could we hold off on the comparisons to
Satan
until at least the midterms
and Biden has had a big problem with the
Satan comparisons because he gave that
speech in front of the big ominous sort
of infernal red backdrop with the
screaming and the yelling and calling
everyone fascist and he's got that guy
who works for him in the monkey pox
office who wears pentagrams on his chest
over his pentagram tattoo and he's got
that sort of demonic looking fellow who
thinks that he's a woman he's the
assistant Health secretary who's always
talking about how we need to castrate
little kids and put them on cross-sex
hormones and then we've got that other
guy who's in the energy nuclear energy
office
who I I referenced a little bit earlier
photographed some so he dress puts on
dresses and high heels and he
photographs himself leading grown men
around and in these sort of leather dog
costumes on a leash and it's all just
kind of
it all seems kind of satanic doesn't it
and Biden's always talking about how
we're in a battle for the soul of our
nation and then here you can see the the
joke he was trying to make the joke he's
trying to make is his dad saying hey
buddy stop criticizing me you're you're
comparing me to God but you know hey
compare me to the devil I look pretty
good actually
but then it's because it's followed up
with
right Biden opens it he says
essentially who are you going to compare
me to God or the devil and then he
follows it up with we want to kill a
bunch of babies and Republicans want to
save a bunch of babies the choice is
clear well that's obvious he's
Biden in that comparison is on the side
of the devil and so he deleted it why do
you think he had to delete it because
even Joe Biden and his handlers looked
at it they said oh darn man we look like
the devil ugh that's not a good look you
don't want to look like the devil
speaking of tweets
huge news on Twitter news that I am I am
at least
55 surprised by
the Elon Musk Twitter deal is going
through
you know very often I predict the future
I've got my Nostradamus hat I've got my
crystal ball
this I did not predict I'm not entirely
surprised by it but I thought that Elon
Musk was basically uh creating a big
publicity storm but ultimately faking it
when he was trying to buy Twitter and
that actually may have been right in the
sense that he did seem to try to get out
of the Twitter deal from the legal
perspective it started to look like he
was not going to be let out of the
Twitter deal so he was just going to be
forced by the courts to buy Twitter
anyway or pay huge fines and so uh now
Elon Musk has said okay I will buy
Twitter for the price that I initially
said I would buy it for and Twitter has
accepted musk's offer Twitter issued a
statement today quote or yesterday
rather we received the letter from the
musk parties which they have filed with
the SEC the intention of the company is
to close the transaction at 54.20 per
share so this is great
weather musk has to buy it now because
he really wants to buy it or whether
it's because he's forced to buy it by
circumstances which I think is probably
more likely either way it's great Elon
Musk running Twitter is going to be a
huge improvement over the lib
oligarchs who control it now who are
putting their thumb not just their thumb
on the scales they're putting their
whole foot on the scales for the libs
when it comes to elections and we've got
one of those coming up
but also when it comes to just the
regular day-to-day of politics they
suppress the conservatives
they amplify the liberals so yeah that's
great
however
this doesn't solve the problem I've been
talking for the past couple days on this
show
about how
the left and the right have
given away our self-government to
private corporations and to more private
interests
and yes those corporations work in
tandem with certain parts of the state
but the corporations are even less
accountable than the state in many cases
why has the left done this well because
they don't have to deal with that sort
of accountability so the the left can
create a bunch of front groups the left
can you you see this with BLM and antifa
the left doesn't want to go in in most
cases and actually send the police to
attack their political opponents they do
it sometimes they use the FBI in this
way they just used it against Donald
Trump they're using against pro-lifers
but usually what the left prefers to do
when it wants to threaten and inflict
political violence on its opponents is
it uses these sort of paramilitary front
groups for the Democratic party that
would be BLM or antifa and they go and
they burn and they rape and they kill
and they pillage and then after months
and months of this they get maybe a
little slap on the wrist they say
naughty naughty don't do that again but
if you do we'll bail you out thanks
thanks for the help antifa thanks for
the help BLM
Kamala Harris is going to go raise money
now so you don't have to sit in the
clinic for too long so that's that's
very often what they do
and it covers it gives them a lot of
cover from accountability well why do
the conservatives do it the
conservatives have have given away
self-government in the name of economic
growth they've said well listen the
government's very inefficient Private
Industry is very efficient and so which
is
Private Industry might be more efficient
than the government but there's
bureaucracy in Private Industry also and
so they say okay we're going to have
public-private Partnerships we're just
going to privatize things entirely and
that's great and that'll be much Freer
it's because of a strain of
libertarianism that really crept into
the conservative movement in the latter
part of the 20th century they say
private always good public always bad
and so what does that do well
in some cases it improves things but
when we're talking about Free Speech
when we're talking about the Public
Square if you privatize the Public
Square now all of a sudden you've got a
handful of oligarchs it's not like it's
some thriving free market with lots and
lots of players you're talking about
three or four people right you're
talking about Facebook Twitter Google
that's it right
we got we got
Mark Zuckerberg Jack Doris here now now
Elon Musk okay that's an improvement and
Sundar pichai they're controlling the
Public Square
and they're even less accountable than
members of Congress are to us that's no
good it does the Elon Musk purchase of
Twitter doesn't solve the problem it
improves things tactically for a little
while but we need to figure out a way if
we are to restore any semblance of
self-government and the traditional
American way of life
it's not enough to say okay well we've
now we've got our billionaire
corporate CEO running things
good they previously had their
billionaire corporate CEO but now we've
got our billionaire no if we want to
restore any semblance of self-government
we need to say no no the corporations
actually don't get to run the whole
government
they can they have a lot of power but
but we the people in the political
Community we're going to wield some
power too
and you're you're seeing this for so
many years the Republicans just carried
water for corporations frequently
corporations that hated our guts and now
you're you really saw it starting with
Trump you see it especially with
DeSantis you're starting to see that
turn no longer do we hear well you know
if you don't if you don't like uh half
the country being censored and the
president of the United States being
de-platformed then you know build your
own Twitter no I don't think we're going
to do that I think we're going to take
over Twitter perhaps through private
means first like Elon Musk I hope I
think he's certainly more on our side
than the other guys are but then we're
we're going to exert influence on
Twitter as a political community that is
very much our right it's actually Our
obligation if we want to have a
constitutional republic
now
fellas we have got a brand new show out
on daily wire plus it's called
breakaways with Allison Williams if you
have not heard Allison was a successful
ESPN sideline reporter but when ESPN
insisted that everyone get that fouchy
ouchy she refused why because she was
trying to get pregnant
and was
rightly worried about potential side
effects of the vaccine so rather than
take the risk she quit good Honor on
breakaways Allison sits down with
athletes who took a stand for their
beliefs the first four episodes feature
Jonathan Isaac Nick rolovich Inez Canter
freedom and Dana White those episodes
are available now and four additional
episodes are coming soon head on over to
dailywire.com Knowles right now to
become a member and watch the series
that is daily
wire.com slash Knowles
speaking of less than ideal Arrangements
Tom Brady
news reports are out now that even Tom
Brady and his supermodel wife Giselle I
don't know how to pronounce her maiden
name boonjin bungen I don't know his his
very beautiful wife Giselle are
reportedly hiring divorce lawyers and
looking to split up
I'm not all that interested in covering
tabloid stories I'm not all that
interested
I I feel very bad for Tom Brady and his
wife and especially for their kids
but this is not just a private matter
sometimes you hear people say oh you
know if a guy's going to get divorced
That's Just A Private Matter stay out of
his private life it's not A Private
Matter
marriage is a public institution that's
why you do it in public
that's why you register it with the
state and before before you registered
it with the state you would register it
with the church which was frequently
established by the state there has
always been a public component here you
take your marriage vows
not just to your spouse but before God
before some kind of Minister whether
it's a priest or it's a minister of the
a Justice of the Peace
and usually you may take those vows
before your friends and family and the
whole community
at the very least you have to do it
before a witness right even if you go to
the Elvis chapel in Vegas you got to do
it before a witness so this is a public
matter it actually is our business
and it's it's very sad I'm sure these
people are going through a ton of pain
right now
but I think it is our responsibility
as Citizens not be not friends of Tom
Brady I don't know Tom Brady
not as you know people who are in the
family but our responsibility as
Citizens to say
they shouldn't do this
they shouldn't do this I I know it's a
fallen world and people have tough
marriages and people go through rough
patches
I have never seen a family improved by
divorce
sometimes in in very rare cases there is
even there is not only a right but an
obligation to have some kind of
Separation let's say that I don't know
the husband is a knock down violent
abusive drunk and he's thrown his wife
against the walls and sometimes for the
for just the protection of one's own
life and the life of One's Own kids
there is some separation that might be
required
say until the you know the husband goes
to rehab or something like that figures
out his life I'm not I'm not denying
that
but as a rule I have never ever seen a
family improved by divorce
these people I don't know anything about
their circumstances I don't know did
someone cheat on someone did someone I
actually I don't think that's even being
reported right now what's being reported
is that Tom Brady and his wife are
getting divorced or might be getting
divorced because they had an argument
over whether Tom was going to retire
from football or not
and she was upset that he didn't spend
enough time with the kids and she didn't
want to go back to work or whatever
again this is all tabloid trash I have
no idea what's actually going on in the
marriage
and I don't really care
figure it out
figure it out but it doesn't it's not
reparable at this point it's it's
absolutely the marriage is just beyond
repair
no it isn't I I asked before I got
married I was I was asking for marital
advice from lots of people and some of
the best I said how do you avoid getting
divorced 50 of marriages or something
end in divorce right now so many of my
friends and family members their parents
were divorced how do you avoid divorce
how do you keep a marriage together
and and the best advice I heard was very
simple they said oh well the best way to
keep your marriage together and have a
long marriage is just just don't get
divorced just work through it
all marriages are going to go through
rough patches
any two people who spend enough time
together are gonna going to have
disagreements and going to have periods
where they they really don't like one
another but there is something greater
than your individual desires
certainly the kids
interests should come before the
interests of the parents
but the marriage itself is an
institution
and as we weaken marriage culturally
politically legally as we weaken that
the whole country is going to weaken
they they should not get divorced I was
I was
also very taken with the Kim and Kanye
divorce story because you all heard all
these people well he is kind of crazy
and she doesn't like what he's doing and
they disagree over this that yeah who
cares Kim Kardashian goes and and she
does an interview with one of the glossy
magazines and she says you know I'm just
not happy right now and I just want to
my 40s are going to be about me no it
shouldn't be it shouldn't be about you
at all and I don't and I don't care if
you don't feel happy at this particular
moment you're not going to feel happy at
every single moment of your life
that's why it's a fallen world
there are more important things than
your
individual pleasure at any given moment
just work it out work it out and this is
I'm giving this commentary not to stick
my nose in Tom Brady's business or
anyone else's business for that matter
I'm doing it because it's it's true
neither of these people will be happier
in the long run if they get divorced
I've never seen it if you're if you're
listening to this and you've been
divorced are you really happier are you
really happier do you really think your
life is better because you got divorced
maybe your wife left you maybe your
husband left you maybe it was something
that you really couldn't avoid I I'm not
I'm not casting stones
but on the topic of divorce itself are
you really happier no no I've never met
anyone who could tell me that they're
really happier by that speaking of
attacks on the Family
Planned Parenthood is peddling puberty
blockers to kids that the kids that they
that slip through the fingers of Planned
Parenthood the kids who are actually
able to live and be born Planned
Parenthood says okay we weren't able to
get you in the womb but we are going to
destroy your bodies and your lives once
you're out of the womb here's the
commercial they're running
there's no one-size-fits-all puberty
experience if your trans intersex or
non-binary know that you're not the only
one feeling confused
for some intersex people puberty may
start later than age 14. you might
experience some of puberty's changes and
not others and your body may or may not
go through puberty on its own there are
medicines you can take to help your body
start the process like hormone
replacement therapy
some people decide on hormones or
surgeries to help their bodies match up
to their gender identity or how they
feel inside about themselves
your gender identity is real you should
be the one to decide what changes you
want to make to your body
if you're transgender or non-binary you
may find that your puberty experiences
don't line up with your gender identity
or how you see yourself that feeling can
be uncomfortable scary and stressful if
that sounds like you know that you're
not alone
there are medicines you can take to
delay puberty for a while they're called
puberty blockers and they work like a
stop sign by halting the hormones
testosterone and estrogen that cause
puberty changes like facial hair growth
and periods puberty blockers are safe
and can give you more time to figure out
what feels right for you man that's the
weirdest episode of Scooby-Doo I ever
saw isn't it I know Velma looks a little
bit different not all that much
different I guess
it's hard even to single out Planned
Parenthood here for this perverted evil
attack on children though it is
obviously both of those things because
the whole culture is doing it because
Scooby Dooby Doo is doing it
so of course Planned Parenthood is going
to do it why why are all these people
doing this
there's an ideological incentive earlier
I said whoever controls the past
controls the president whoever controls
the press and controls the future that's
that's true it's missing a little
something though
there's actually even a an earlier part
to that equation which is
whoever controls the imagination
controls the past
the imagination is what comes first we
don't have really direct access to the
past we only have access to things that
are in the present
we only have access to people who are in
the present
and those things and those people can
evoke memories but really they're
they're constituting narratives and
those narratives inform our vision which
is just in our imagination of what the
past is so if you if you in your
imagination
uh see America in the 1950s as a nice
place with two cars in every garage and
a chicken in every pot and basically
stable family lives and basically a good
place
that informs one sense of the past and
that's going to inform how you want to
how you view the present and how you
want to live in the future or if in your
imagination you view America in the 50s
as a racist evil bigoted violent
dangerous terrible evil consumerist
trash Place well that's going to give
you a very different view of the past
and the present and it's going to inform
how you want to live into the future why
is Planned Parenthood
so focused on this narrative why is the
whole left so focused on this narrative
well because they have an ideological
agenda absolutely they want the future
to look a certain way because of how
they view human beings in the world
they also have a huge financial interest
in promoting this stuff
do you think it's just a coincidence
that all the biggest most powerful
forces in the country just so happen to
to adopt the ideological View
in this case transgenderism
that just so happens to hook people at
younger and younger ages on extremely
expensive medical subscriptions that
will require a ton of money it'll be a
huge Money Maker as some Public Health
administrators have talked about here in
Tennessee
and we'll keep them on it their whole
lives
and that just so happened to increase
the corporate and State control over
their lives and their Reliance on
corporations and on the state
yeah it's just a coincidence
that that the the ideological narratives
being painted by the establishment
stand to greatly enrich and Empower that
very same establishment that's just a
coincidence wow lucky for them what a
lucky break no of course not
of course not a lot of this is being
driven by money as well
and as
the The Narrative serves the financial
and political interests of the
establishment
you're seeing the cases of
transgenderism Skyrocket in the UK
there's a new a new tranche of data
released by the gender identity
development service at the UK's Infamous
Tavistock Center
found out that Child and Adolescent
referrals have doubled compared to the
previous year
gids as it is called gids or jids it's
sort of like GIF or GIF now estimates
that over 5 000 Children and adolescents
sought gender related services
in 2021 to 2022 that is a 112 increase
over the previous year
how'd that happen
is Alex Jones right is there something
in the water turning the frogs and
turning Velma and turning everybody gay
and trans he actually was right about
the frogs people don't give him credit
for that but he was right there actually
there was a Yale and EPA study
that found that there were chemicals in
the water that were turning the frogs
into hermaphrodites but that's a point
for another time is it that or do you
think there's a social contagion here
that's that's being compounded that's
being promoted by corporate and state
interests
and and who are the who are the victims
here the victims happen to be these kids
who destroy their bodies who destroy
their lives who become extremely
depressed who who despair even though
there is a way out but there is
irreparable damage that that comes along
with that as well that's what happens
the numbers of course are going to keep
going up because even as normal people
the vast majority of Americans vast
majority of Brits I'm sure think that
this is completely insane and public
opinion polls reflect that and elections
reflect that the the youngin election to
governor in Virginia was largely about
this issue of transiting the kids okay
and he won in a blue state so yeah of
course the people are opposed to this
stuff and yet and yet
it continues to be enshrined in law
what's up with that
what's up with that well because our
political establishment does not reflect
the will of the people much as they want
to prattle on about our sacred democracy
they don't give a damn about our
democracy they hate democracy they hate
it when the people vote against their
interests all they care about is their
version of liberalism and they're going
to impose it they're going to impose it
like a like a Jack boot on our necks and
and they're going to have the temerity
to call it democracy and when we fight
back they're going to have the temerity
to call us threats against democracy
also they can shoot up children with
cross-sex drugs speaking of undesirable
shots
Ron DeSantis and fighting back Ron
DeSantis has just come out I I think
everyone would agree he's done a very
good job dealing with this hurricane uh
this awful awful hurricane that landed
in Florida so Ron DeSantis said okay
some people died fortunately the death
toll was lower than some people were
estimating we've done rescue missions
that's really really great but now when
when property is destroyed when there's
a little bit of political chaos
sometimes bad Men start to loot and Ron
DeSantis comes out and he says look in
this state where the Second Amendment is
fully active when the Looting starts the
shooting starts so beware
the other thing that we're concerned
about particularly in those areas that
were really hard hit is you know we want
to make sure we're maintaining Law and
Order uh don't even think about looting
don't even think about taking advantage
of people in this vulnerable situation
and so local law enforcement is involved
in in in monitoring that you know I told
Kevin if the state needs to help as well
uh because yeah you can have people you
know bringing boats into some of these
islands and trying to ransack people's
homes I can tell you in the State of
Florida you never know what may be
lurking behind somebody's home and I
would not want to chance that if I were
you given that we're a Second Amendment
state
totally right totally and what happens
the libs say you're a racist
you're a terrible racist I I saw this it
was like all of these NPCs all of these
automatons they just got the talking
points right away they said Ron DeSantis
beep boop Ron DeSantis said that looters
will be shot beep boop that's what
racists said in the 60s
looting is a civil right I don't I guess
that's what they're implying
black people don't like to get looted
either Hispanic people don't like to get
looted either
black people have second amendment
rights too Hispanic people have second
amendment rights too
it is very very good it is good for
everybody it is for you might say the
common good
that when the Looting starts the
shooting starts because it will protect
public order it will save lives
ultimately
you don't want bands of marauders going
into people's homes
but this is what they do this is this is
how now I I can ascertain
who a who a good strong political
candidate will be
is how vociferously the left calls that
person racist because racist is just a
synonym for bad it has nothing to do
with race at all really anymore it's
just it's just bad you're a bad person
and the more the libs call you a racist
the more likely you are to be doing the
right thing because they're afraid of
you and they call you the worst thing
that you can be called in society
it has it has nothing to do with race
whatsoever it's just as we don't like
you it's just they use it the same way
that they use democracy right the libs
hate democracy they openly oppose
democracy in many many cases they just
use that word to mean something
completely different it's the same with
racism
and and they're looking terrible
especially with regard to this hurricane
so
DeSantis from the governor's office I
think he did a good job certainly the
First Responders on the scene did an
amazing job in Florida and the president
commended them for that and so he said
these Coast Guard rescue swimmers man
these guys are so great so but the
problem is Joe Biden is currently he's
right now in the process of firing
not only
one of the rescue swimmers who who he
was previously commending in Florida for
saving people but many many other
members of our military because they
won't take the fauci ouchy the president
recently praised a group of Coast Guard
rescue swimmers one of them reportedly
faces termination because he wasn't
vaccinated and I'm curious given the
threats that we're facing abroad with
the president ever reconsider that
vaccination requirement or consider
issuing more exemptions so as you as as
you can imagine the president has the
most the deepest respect for the U.S
Coast Guard that is something that you
would hear from him directly and the
country the president and the country
are grateful for all of the U.S Coast
Guard Heroes that have led the effort to
save lives in Florida we have seen that
with our very own eyes these past couple
of days I would refer you specifically
to the U.S Coast Guard on this on this
issue on this individual questions it's
not something that I would comment from
here but you know there of course have
been multiple vaccination requirements
as you know in place for quite some time
and but again I'm not going to comment
here from here on an individual case
I'm not going to comment here on an
individual case but it's not an
individual case
the vaccine mandate is for all of the
service members
it just so happens that one of the
service members is happens to be one of
the guys that the president just
individually personally commended for
saving lives
but but the reporters asking a policy
question
will the Pres is the president still
going to fire these people oh the
president has the utmost respect for
these people he's still going to take
their jobs away if they don't comply
with taking his shot that
is is not quite so safe and effective as
we were previously told
and which gives people health problems
and kills people in in more cases than
we were told it would I don't know how
am I dancing around the censorship
enough YouTube I don't know I people who
are very wisely not taking this shot in
my humble opinion
yeah but he still has the most respect
for these people
oh yeah the utmost but he's not I'm not
going to comment you got to talk to the
Coast Guard why the Coast Guard didn't
give the order
this order for the vaccine mandate goes
up to the top that's a Biden order
that's a White House order
oh yeah no never mind no we yeah we like
them but we don't like them but we don't
and now they're in the middle of the
road they're getting hit by a truck
that's what's gonna happen
because the Biden Administration is dug
in on its radicalism
the radicalism is not popular especially
this year heading into the midterms in
2022.
so the Biden Administration wants to
seem moderate but they're not willing to
do any of the things that are necessary
to be more moderate
they want the libs do this all the time
I've talked about this on this show from
the very beginning of the show the libs
want the appearance of the thing
without the essence of the thing
they want to appear like women
but not be women right you especially
see this with transgenderism
they want to appear moderate and
reasonable but not be moderate and
reasonable they're the sort of people
who drink decaffeinated coffee right it
seems like coffee but it's missing the
essence of coffee
right these are they they want all the
they want all the symbol but they don't
recognize that the symbol has a
connection to something that is
symbolized and they're doing it here too
they can't do it
and the radicalism is just keeping up
and up but Joe Biden's Energy Secretary
Miguel Cardona was just asked about
uh his priorities in education policy
and he said you know what students
really need to learn there are scores in
math and and verbal are just collapsing
right now students are worse educated
than probably they've ever been in our
country's history and what they really
really need is abortions
I share your grave concerns about
maintaining access to contraception and
reproductive Health Services on our
college campuses
and ensuring there's accurate reliable
information for students and for
educators
students need access to health care to
thrive in school and in life and that
includes reproductive Health Care
I said Energy Secretary I meant to say
education secretary although it's very
confusing because the education
secretary is talking about something
that I suppose the Health and Human
Services secretary should be talking
about it it's all just getting kind of
jumbled and blurred together do you
really think that that's what students
most need in America right now they need
to be able to
kill their own children
if they conceive children which they
probably shouldn't be and we probably
shouldn't be enacting policies that will
encourage them to put themselves in
situations where they might be
conceiving children out of wedlock when
they're still teenagers do you that's
what they really need most no parents
who have become a major voting force in
this country parents as an actual voting
group do you think when they hear that
they say hold on you've screwed my kid
out of his education for two years
you're teaching them all sorts of
insanity right now you're telling him
that it is evil because he's white
you're telling him that he's actually a
woman you're telling him all sorts of
Madness and now now you're saying that
the best thing you're going to do for
kids is give them the opportunity to
kill their own children what that's not
that's not going to be very popular it's
so so radical it is a narrative that
they are pushing but the narrative is
not very persuasive and so what are they
going to do they have two options
they're going to abandon the narrative
or they're going to try to enforce it
even harder which one do you think
they're going to do speaking of pushing
these narratives speaking of everything
every single thing becoming super duper
gay
we have got a a trailer for this movie
that my producers insist that I watch
it's called Bros
it's a movie it didn't do very well
apparently at the box office on opening
weekend it's apparently very very gay
they the The Producers want to know if I
should review this movie give an actual
proper review we'll take a look at the
trailer together you tell me if we
should review the movie the rest of the
show is continuing now you don't want to
miss it if you're not a member click the
link in the description and join us
[Music]
[Music]
thank you